[Music]  that's me Arianna Berlin gymnastics in  life never know what life is gonna throw  you right yeah what if I don't qualify  for the Olympics  you're in the hospital in a coma honey  gymnastics is pretty much off the table  I need to go to the Olympics  Arianna hey well thank you and you know  you could still compete if you want  something you'll have to fight hard for  it and what if something I really want  is no longer attainable better get ready  you're going out so welcome to power  once he meets I've been asking about you  you can't stay away forever you know and  where am I going to do gymnastics UCLA  Arianna Berlin right if you're gonna  come back to gymnastics you need to come  back like you really mean it  you  [Music]  starting to realize my limitations I  guess I don't think you know a mean of  limitations they literally cannot stop  you unless they hit you with a car  this isn't about gymnastic it's about  life  you  [Music]  hello Danny